بدأت الزراعة يمكن من عمري ثلاث سنوات مع الوالد
كان يعلمنا نزرع الفجل، أذكرها من وأنا عمري ثلاث سنوات
كان يزيل الفجل وبعدين يحطه في الحواف عشان يطلع
يخلي تقاوي البذور
من لما كنت سبع سنوات إلى اليوم، خمس وسبعين الحين
أنا أسقي بالليل وبالنهار أطلع النخل فوق
وبالليل أسقيه بالماي
ورحنا اشتغلنا
فعندنا أدوات البناء، واشتغلنا مما اشتغلنا
بس مثل ما قلت لك، كلمة برجعها عليك
يقول لك إن كنت تكد كد الوحوش
غير رزقك يا عبدي ما تحوش
يعني كل مسار يكون لون
فيه عندنا الطماطم خمسة ألوان
فلفل أربعة ألوان
وقرع وباذنجان وفليفلة
يعني متعددة في نفس البيت
الإنسان يبي الشيء اللي يريحه
لكن هذه الزراعة الفلاحة تعب، ترى ما كل واحد يقدر يشتغلها
فيه ناس لو تجيبه يشتغل لك يوم، ما يمرها يوم ثاني
وفيه ناس يقول لك لا، أنا هذه حياتي
هذا الشهر تزرع هنا، الشهر الجاي هنا
اخترب ذاك ازرع هذا
غرس وحشّ، الأول طلع الثاني
شيل من هالممر وحط في هالممر
ما فيه راحة
الماي بسرعة بسرعة
إيه، عدل
اسحب اسحب
تعودنا على التعب، ومثل ما يقولون لك الضغط والتعب
تعلمنا عليها تعودنا عليها
بيّض الله وجهك
أقول لك نعم ذيب ذيب
الفلاح الأحسائي مستحيل يستغنى عن زرعه
يشرب الشاي العصر في المزرعة، تمره من المزرعة، خضرته من المزرعة
عنده دجاج ولا غنم في المزرعة، وين يروح؟
ما يقدر يفارقها، ولو قعدت ما أكلت
يا يكدّ له نخل، يا عنده حلال وأرض
مثلًا في موسم الأرز، بنطبن الأرض يعني بنحط لها طبينة
سعف النخل ننزله، ونحرق الأرض
حصدنا الأرز وانتهى، بنغرس بعده بامية
حصاده تعب في الحرارة
تخلص حصاد تبتدئ تسميد، تخلص تسميد تبتدئ تجنيم
بعدها النبات بعد التعديل
والحين جات السوسة لها حوالي عشرين سنة ثلاثين سنة
وصارت شغلة إضافية على الفلاح وعبء
يعني لو جات للنخلة، راحت النخلة عمرها خمسة وعشرين سنة
تروح في في شهر تهلكها
من تسع سنوات ثمان سنوات، الحين يصعد لك النخلة
يعتمد علي، يمشي الوالد
حتى لو يسافر ولّا شيء يعتمد علي
في عمر أربعة عشر إلى خمسة عشر سنة
يعني ثلاث سنوات غالبًا عشان يحفظه عن الشارع
بعدين خمس سنوات ست سنوات لا مسؤول
يعني مسؤول فيها عقاب
الشكل يكون كأنه واحد كبير، وأنا عمري صغير
أوقات تحتاج المزرعة نجيها في نص الليل
ونجيها مثلًا عزّ الظهر في الصيف
اللي ما عنده صبر ما يقدر يزرع
يقاوم لين يغرق، هذه الفلاحة
من مارسها بدون لا يعرف، ما صار فلاح
الفلاح يصبر ويزرع مرة ثانية وثالثة ورابعة وعاشرة
ما ييأس
ما أقدر أسافر وأترك النخل
فلا تفكر المزارع في الأحساء يقدر يستغني
حتى لو قال لك بترك الزراعة
وين يروح أصلًا؟